desde la ropa hasta el champú pasando
por los artículos para bebés y la
tecnología estos son algunos de los
productos que evitarán un destino fatal
en la basura gracias a una nueva ley que
ha entrado en vigor en francia me parece
una gran idea es una idea mucho mejor
que desecharlos si podemos reducir los
residuos y la incineración
todos los días vemos gente buscando en
la basura ponen todo lo que pueden en
carros y carritos para reutilizar
mientras que las empresas queman
entierran y tiran red unos 4500 millones
de dólares en bienes sin contar
alimentos se quedan sin vender cada año
en la nación gala y el 15 por ciento es
decir casi 700 millones de dólares en
nuevos productos se convierten en humo o
se entierran en vertederos ahora la ley
exige que esa mercancía se done a
organizaciones benéficas se vendan a
tiendas de descuento o se reciclen
estos son nuestros productos de higiene
pero son productos y compramos porque
son una gran necesidad
creo que esta ley animará a más empresas
a donar y no a destruir porque más de 3
millones de personas en francia no
tienen acceso a productos esenciales
como los de higiene las empresas pueden
ser multadas con hasta 15 mil euros si
no siguen las nuevas normas de respeto
al medio ambiente